so I've already laid out for you the
BuzzFeed news story about Donald Trump
directing Michael Cohen to lie to
Congress which would be felony
obstruction of justice if true I already
told you that Robert Muller put out this
very narrowly carefully worded statement
about it and I told you that BuzzFeed
news is standing by the story okay now
we have to get into some seriously
damaging realities about this for Donald
Trump which are that both the White
House and his attorney Rudy Giuliani one
of trumps many lawyers are not denying
that this happened is described Fox News
interviewed White House spokesperson
Hogan Gidley
about this report and giggly could have
denied it multiple times and he did not
now remember Robert Muller statement
said that some specific statements and
characterizations of documents are not
accurate that is very very different
than Donald Trump didn't do it at all
okay here's Hogan Gidley with every
opportunity to simply say it didn't
happen tell me what you make of this
how's their president responding to that
report this morning this is absolutely
absolutely ludicrous that we are giving
any type of credence or credibility to a
news outlet like BuzzFeed they are
responsible completely and totally for
the release of a discredited disproven
false dossier and now the author of the
piece in question that you're talking
about went on air this morning and said
he couldn't corroborate any of his own
evidence he ran it anyway this is quite
frankly the problem with the press and
why the president continues to call them
so ad hominem BuzzFeed is bad he claims
that the steel dossier is false that's
not true more and more of it has
actually been corroborated since its
release and then he says that BuzzFeed
that President Trump is right to call
BuzzFeed and others fake news which is
of course not an argument this interview
continues and again opportunities for
Hogan Gidley to say the story's not true
but he doesn't do it I think the way it
was characterized the reporter did not
see specifically the evidence but relied
on one or two sources that they had
trusted for this right but that's not
news that's something he sees and he
puts
out there it's the same reason in
rationale behind a dossier that is
called this cause this entire fake
witch-hunt Russia investigation and now
it's all been disproven so once again he
says the dossier was the sole basis for
the Trump Russia investigation that's
not true he says that it's a witch-hunt
well we've had more than a dozen
indictments already and he says that
it's all been disproven which is simply
not true but missing there once again is
any kind of denial it continues it was
the president did not tell Michael Cohen
to do that I'm telling you right now
this is exactly why the president
refuses to give any credence or
credibility to news outlets because they
have no ability to corroborate anything
they're putting out there instead
they're just using innuendo and shady
sources that was not a denial of my
question no but but but the premise is
ridiculous we're also talking about a
person in michael cohen who quite
frankly has now been proven to be a liar
he Suffolk myths that he's a felon that
is not a denial bill hemmer points out
and Hogan Gidley says yeah that's true
and then they just ad hominem michael
cohen which again is not only not a
denial it's not even really an argument
every opportunity here path to issue
even a muted denial or a partial denial
but he doesn't do it and it could simply
be hogan Gidley Bigley what would a now
i'm forgetting his name he just doesn't
want to go to prison and he knows that
it probably is true that this took place
yeah but it's not like it's a crime to
the lights of the media it's not like
he's going out there in front of
Congress or he's under oath in some
sense so it wouldn't be something
criminal for him to do that but maybe he
wants to save face and maybe protect his
reputation future job prospects that
sort of thing I don't uh I don't I don't
disagree whatsoever it simply tells us
more than anything else that there
probably is a lot to this story and then
after Hogan giddily bid Lee had now I'm
not even sure what his name is
in comes Rudy Giuliani that name I'm
sure of and he straight up plays that
yeah and so what game trying to distract
from the content of this conversation
that might have taken place between
Donald Trump and Michael Cohen ignoring
the the question of whether Trump told
Cohen to lie simply saying yes so what
if Mike of Michael Cohen did have a
conversation with Trump
about his testimony as far as I know
President Trump did not have discussions
with him certainly had no discussions
with him in which he told them or
counseled him to lie if if he had any
discussions with him they'd be about the
version of the events that Michael Cohen
gave then which they all believed was
true I believed it was true I still
believe it may be true because unlike
these people who want to just believe
him I believe Michael Cohen is a serial
liar if you can figure out what Michael
Cohen's telling the truth you're better
than I am j-just again horsey ride might
have talked to him about about his
testimony and so what if you talk to is
it not possible that Michael can't ride
that conversation I'm just asking you
for what what happened or what didn't
happen she's not possible the President
Obama left the conversation thinking
well this is what the boss wants me to
say the boss wants me not possible the
guy driving this testimony was Michael
Cohen so consider what Giuliani is
saying yes it actually may be true that
Donald Trump had a conversation with
Michael Cohen about the testimony but he
definitely didn't tell him to lie
although Giuliani doesn't know what
happened in the conversation how can a
person be so sure about the content of a
conversation that he has no idea whether
even it took place or not it's it's by
definition absurd Giuliani has no way of
knowing that Cohen was not directed to
lie if he doesn't know what was or
wasn't said during that conversation and
likewise this so what game that they're
playing this is increasingly the only
game Giuliani has left no no there were
definitely wasn't any collusion oh well
listen collusion is not actually a crime
I don't know of any crime that's
actually called collusion this is the so
what game that they're increasingly
playing and I would also add that the
timing of all of this is extraordinarily
suspicious because as this entire Cohen
thing was ramping up Trump was on
increasingly bad terms with Michael
Cohen so the idea that they had this
sort of friendly inconsequential
conversation about the testimony without
discussing what it is that Donald Trump
would prefer Michael Cohen to saying to
say is probably the least believable
version of this story altogether
so when you step back for a second and
get above the back and forth about
adjudicating the BuzzFeed news
statements word-for-word and Muller
statements about mischaracterizations
word-for-word what you get to is that
Donald Trump's own lawyer Rudy Giuliani
is admitting yes actually Trump may have
spoken to Coen about the testimony but
he definitely didn't tell him what to
say and if he did he was only telling
him what to say because he believed that
to be the most accurate version of the
events this is simply not believable
particularly when Rudy Giuliani on all
of these issues has been going in the
direction of the if it happened so what
point of view so my best guess right now
about what happened is that buds
BuzzFeed's report is correct that there
was some kind of admittedly maybe vague
evidence that Donald Trump did direct
Michael Cohen to lie but it's not as
specific as the characterization that
BuzzFeed news gave a Cohen claims that
he was directed to lie by Donald Trump
maybe there's a text message or an email
or a recording that sort of
circumstantially defends it but it
certainly wouldn't be what the Special
Counsel calls incontrovertible evidence
that would be likely to get anybody a
conviction and it's also quite possible
that the inaccuracy in the BuzzFeed news
story is merely that the testimony
wasn't given to the special counsel but
rather to the Southern District of New
York which has been doing a lot of the
work here because if we put the quote
back up for a second you'll notice that
what the statement says is BuzzFeed's
description of specific statements to
the special counsels office it may be
that the statements are exactly as
described but they were made to the
Southern District of New York
prosecutors and investigators rather
than to the special counsels office so
that clarification statement from Muller
spokesperson could merely be a
disagreement on the venue and it would
still fully allow the spirit of the
BuzzFeed news story to be true simply
not a statements made to the special
counsel's office will we
ever know the full truth that I
certainly hope so send me your thoughts
about the story send me at your thoughts
about where you are on it at this point
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show
I'm on Twitter at Dee Pakman follow us
both and send me your comments I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka Steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I put a link in the description
I have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
NK is t-dot-com forward slash PA k ma n